being a cartoonist in 2019 is quite a
dizzying experience everywhere you turn
there's a mountain of cartoon material
being created on your behalf by the
world's politicians the prize this week
for kooky cartoon conduct goes once
again
to the mad cluster shambles of brexit
since Britain formally announced two
years ago its intention to leave the
European Union things have not gone
smoothly the EU fearing other members
might be tempted to follow Britain out
the door was in no mood to make the
transition easy for the Brits it
maintained a unified front and clearly
held the upper hand in negotiations over
the terms for Britain's departure back
in London the hapless Prime Minister
Theresa May had her hands full while her
own party dithered the opposition Labour
Party blustered May scrambled to
assemble a popular plan for brexit now
with just weeks remaining before britain
unceremoniously crashes out of the EU
there is no such plan in sight in a
desperate attempt to find a way forward
raucous debates were held in Parliament
this week the outcome of all these
histrionics was a stern assignment for
the prime minister she was instructed to
re-engage with the EU and demand they
reopen talks over the breaks a deal and
been to the British demands well you can
guess how that went over in European
capitals with a dangerous brexit
deadline looming I fear this power
struggle is one the hapless Teresa may
is unlikely to win
you